senator Bernie Sanders is with us he is
a member of the Budget Committee in the
Senate and what can you tell us about
how the stimulus bill is shaping up in
the Senate well as you know it passed
the House yesterday I think we'll be
voting on it next week it got out of
appropriations committee yesterday Susan
I don't have to tell any of the
listeners that our country today faces
most significant economic and financial
crisis we have faced since the Great
Depression on my state we're
hemorrhaging jobs you read in the papers
the other day 70,000 jobs lost in one
day people losing their savings their
their retirement accounts on Wall Street
people's homes are being foreclosed kids
are not able to afford to continue to go
to college so we have some major major
problems that we face and I think after
eight years of one of the most
disastrous administration's in the
history of this country it is time to
move us in a new direction that is what
the campaign was about that's what
Barack Obama ran on and I think it is
time instead of giving tax breaks to
billionaires and continuing the war in
Iraq at ten billion dollars a month I
think we start investing in the middle
class and working families I think we
start creating the millions of jobs that
we desperately need rebuilding our
crumbling infrastructure I know in my
state I suspect a love of this country
our roads are in terrible shape bridges
water systems and also a president obama
have making this point for decades we
have been talking about energy
independence the need not to input seven
hundred billion dollars e or foreign oil
let's do it let's start creating the
kind of sustainable energy and the
energy efficiencies that we need in the
United States start moving to wind solar
geothermal biomass and over a period of
time we can create millions of jobs
doing that I think also what you're
going to see in this economic recovery
program is an understanding not only
that we have to create millions of jobs
we have to take care of those people
have been hurt by this recession people
have lost their jobs lost their health
care lost their housing you just can't
leave them on the side of the street so
you're going to see an investment in
health care and in a number of respects
we're also going to do our best to make
sure that college becomes a little bit
more affordable by expanding Pell grants
so
through a variety of ways we're going to
start paying attention to the needs of
working families in the middle class
rather than just the wealth ian and
corporate america and start turning this
country about a couple of questions just
listening to many of the comments made
or questions asked during the past two
hours first of all on the jobs creation
side you even use the phrase over the
long term if people need jobs now what's
in the package that creates jobs well no
we've all heard this new expression
shovel-ready and and what that means is
that we are going to be investing in
those projects that are ready to stop
moving and putting people to work
immediately within the next six months
within the next year so I with a
crumbling infrastructure and engineers
tell us we have over a trillion dollars
of unmet infrastructure needs in this
country we know in our bridges are in
terrible shape roads are in terrible
shape my state water systems both clean
water and wastewater I need significant
improvements so you're going to see
probably the largest investment in
infrastructure which puts people to work
immediately we talked about it in my
state we have done a pretty good job we
have a long way to go in terms of energy
efficiency we are a cold-weather state a
lot of senior citizens don't have a lot
of money have homes that are poorly
insulated they need new storm windows
they need new roofs you're going to see
investments in millions of homes all
over this country building schools so
these are jobs it's both the short term
immediately I think President Obama is
talking about the need to create
millions of jobs within the next couple
of years but will lay the basis I think
for a healthier economy in in the long
run I promised a caller that missed you
by a few minutes I would ask the
question for him he is the smallest of
small business owners seven employees
coffee company in Texas has an SBA small
business loan and he's almost ready to
declare blank bankruptcy he says is
there anything in this package for me I
think there is I really do think there
is I think we're going to try through
low-interest loans to help the small
business community clearly we know and
are go on to this for about five hours
in the outrage of what has taken place
on Wall Street which to my mind Susan
constitutes probably
significant and largest criminal act in
the history of our country you have had
a handful of people 100 few hundred
people on Wall Street who through their
incredible greed their recklessness the
illegal behavior has brought a financial
system to the verge of collapse and has
created an economic climate but which we
have been lose millions of jobs small
business as this gentleman is involved
in has been the engine where we've
created jobs we got to stop protecting
small business provide them the kind of
loans and help that they need so that we
can grow jobs at the grassroots level do
you expect a Justice Department led by
eric holder will pursue prosecutions I
think that's one of the avenues we've
got to go but let me be very clear about
this I think that the people on Wall
Street who committed this crime and I
use the word crime advisedly have got to
be punished I think that the greed that
they have expressed we're making twenty
percent rates of return was not enough
earning hundreds of millions of dollars
was not enough that they had to create
these new financial instruments these
derivatives these credit default swaps
which have led us to where they are they
have got to pay a price for that and
more importantly not only do we have to
hold them accountable through a very
very thorough investigation but what we
also have to do is make sure that we do
not go back to where we were and that
means we have to deal with this
phenomenon too big to fail create these
huge financial institutions and when
they get in trouble we have to bail them
out if they're too big to fail in my
view they are too big to exist let's
start breaking them up right now
furthermore when we talk about the
economy we've got to pay attention to
health care we remain the only country
in the industrialized world that does
not guarantee health care every man
woman and child is a right of scissors
here sure we got to deal with the
growing disparity of income and wealth
in this country with the top one-tenth
of 1% earn more income than the bottom
fifty percent so we have I mean I really
don't envy President Obama the list of
problems that are on his desk with a ten
point six trillion dollar national debt
to was foreign was we've got some
problems but i do believe with new
leadership as a nation we can come
together and start turning this country
around in a way very different ways
what we went on the bush for eight years
not surprisingly our lines are all
lighted up for people to talk to you
beginning with Omaha you're on the air
for senator Sanders good morning senator
solids at the other speak to you the
question I have is I'm hearing all the
things that we're we should be doing but
I want to ask the Republicans is if we
took up all the things that the
Democrats are proposing and we have the
power to manage it just tell us what
would you do what would what do you ask
whatever you asking us what would you do
to solve the problem we hear the place
that you're saying that you don't want
us to do so just tell us what would you
do and we'll look at it and let's see
what you would do to solve the problems
at hand for us because again when Bush
came out and I say we need 750 billion
dollars they wit for that and they were
all in it and voted for that so please
just tell us what would you do many
people did both of that this senator did
not vote for that I voted against the
first bailout I voted against the second
bailout these are very difficult issues
but I could not vote in good conscience
to allow the middle class of this
country people who standard of living
has been in decline to bail out
corporate crooks who have made hundreds
and hundreds of millions of dollars so i
voted against that but i believe in
terms of the economic recovery program
the time is long overdue for us to start
investing in our people we have the
highest rate of childhood poverty in the
industrialized world this economic
recovery package will put billions of
dollars into headstart into childcare so
our kids can get a fair start in life
and working families can know that their
kids are taking care of in a decent way
in my state and all over this country
people are paying outrageously high
property taxes this legislation will put
a lot of money into special education so
that communities and school districts
around the country can perhaps see a
lowering of their property taxes and
school districts will not have to be
laying off of teachers again in terms of
energy I believe that it is imperative
from an
national security perspective and from a
global warming perspective that we move
away from fossil fuels and foreign oil
this legislation spots ending all the
talk that we've been hearing for years
for decades it starts investing in wind
solar geothermal biomass energy
efficiency so I think all of those
things are very positive now I'm not
going to tell you that in a 900 billion
dollar piece of legislation they're not
things that I would disagree with I do
for example among other things I think
the tax breaks and there are too high
but there is a lot of very good
investment in this for the American
people and I believe very strongly that
after eight years of giving tax breaks
to billionaires after a war in Iraq
which cost us 10 billion dollars a month
the time is now start investing in the
American people creating good-paying
jobs rebuilding our country Pensacola
good morning republican line good
morning i think your guests best
illustrates what's wrong with our
economy you have a Congress that is
ninety percent attorneys I'm not sure
senator Sanders is or not doesn't really
matter but the problem is this I know
high school kids that could write a
better loan application to what Congress
gave to these banks let me give you a
specific example when the insurance
company i g-got their money they paid
out bonuses some multi-millions
mid-level managers the CEO said well we
have to keep our good people they've
experienced four consecutive quarters a
loss of 4.3 billion dollars now any
company I've ever worked for would throw
you on the street if your division was
remarkably as an apt as AIG was this is
what we need instead of having lawyers
elected to Congress what we need are
businessmen scientists people who know
what they're talking about senator
Sanders doesn't know the first thing
about energy there is no electric
battery manufactured anywhere on this
planet that can drive an 18-wheel truck
you could take all the alternative
energy that can be produced in this
country it will not amount to more than
five percent of what
we need we need we are going to need
fossil fuels for at least the next 20
years so instead of the Democrats
talking about alternative and green
energies all the stuff that won't work
they need to start developing our
resources we have now as technology
comes online all right let me jump in
sir Thanks now let me mention to the
gentleman again I'm not a lawyer as it
happens the problem I don't I don't know
how many lawyers there are in Congress
there are many but you really want to
know what the problem is it's not
lawyers in Congress it is the impact of
large corporations and their lobbyists
on what goes on in Washington there is a
reason why over the last eight years we
have given tax breaks to people who
don't need it why we have given tax
breaks to oil companies who have seen
record-breaking profits while the middle
class and working families have gotten
relatively little so what we have is a
culture here in Washington is where
big-money interests have enormous power
and working people have far too little
influence in terms of the bailout I
happen to agree with the gentleman I
voted against it but I want him to know
if he's on the Republican line the
President Bush came to Congress after
telling us for seven years how strong
and I hope everybody remembers this
remember the expression the fundamentals
of the economy are strong the economy is
robust that's what Bush said over and
over again and then finally one day half
a year ago Hank Paulson walks into
Congress so we made a little bit of a
mistake it turns out if you don't give
me seven hundred billion dollars to do
as I want to do no strings attached the
world's financial system is going to
collapse that was George Bush Hank
Paulson Congress ended up saying no
that's not acceptable you got to do a B
and C I didn't accept what Congress said
I voted against it so clearly the first
350 billion dollars to my mind has not
been a successful uh we asked the banks
today what did you do with the money
they are not even telling us what they
don't which is outrageous so but in
terms of sustainable energy I strongly
disagree with the call i think there's
huge potential it's sitting out there
waiting to happen to move us away from
fossil fuels and it's imperative that we
do that both from an energy independence
perspective as well as
dealing with greenhouse gas emissions
while we're talking about the the tarp
program front page business day New York
Times Geithner says financial plan is in
the works a comprehensive plan to repair
the financial system to be announced
soon well clearly it is it is needed the
idea that you had people on Wall Street
operating without transparency we had
Alan Greenspan phil gramm and Democrats
as well of making the incredible
argument that let's deregulate these
guys let's break down the walls so that
we could have these large incredibly
large financial institutions are and
then let them invest in any way they
want without any transparency without
any government regulations without any
accountability this is somehow according
to alan greenspan going to be really
really great for the economy and create
prosperity for i was on the house
financial institutions committee for 16
years i voted against the repeal of the
glass Stegall legislation it did not
make a lot of sense to me then but this
whole philosophy of deregulation that
Wall Street do what they want to do tax
breaks for billionaires unfettered
international free trade that is a
philosophy that may have worked for the
rich and the powerful but not for the
middle class it's time to rethink it of
course we need to re-regulate
specifically yesterday stock Sir John
Wall Street as this notes on the hopes
that the government was moving toward
creating a bad bank to purge toxic
assets from balance sheets do you
support that well this is a complicated
issue that we're going to have to look
at the concern here is I simply do not
want to bail out Wall Street with
taxpayers paying the bill I want to
create a situation where if we're going
to invest in financial institutions in
the long run the American people who
have invested in it gained from that
investment osceola iowa independent line
good morning caller are you there hello
yes sir you're on oh I just came right
on through Bernie how are you You
certainly have constituents in your area
who are on your side and a number who
are not hear me yes are you fine all
right I gotta ask you
a question it's been bothering me for a
long time you're the of my hero in a lot
of ways I gotta ask you do you believe
that this country owes reparations for
the slaves bottom line Bonnie payments
no I think no that would not be no
that's not one of the issues very high
on my priority list bath maine go ahead
place good morning senator I had my
problem my biggest problem you folks you
know in your committees SAT around for
the last month or so arguing about what
the auto dealers should be getting and
what the CEO should be paid and how they
had failed their companies in a way that
they ran their companies the way I look
at it the last eight years the Senate or
the entire United States Congress has
failed this country have you folks
thought about taking a one dollar a year
pay cut or wound all year pay for the
entire year and let your funds your
money this 175 + thousand dollars to the
day you die go into their office to help
us out first of all it's not 100 you
know something it is not a hundred and
seventy five thousand dollars a year to
the day you die it is true that there is
a pension there was an older pension for
people who are elected earlier the
pension that I receive is a good pension
it is comparable to the private sector I
think if you ended up having members of
Congress work for a dollar a year you
would end up having millionaires and
billion as being the only people in
Congress who could afford to take that
job and I don't think that that is
acceptable but I think in terms of what
we see nationally 175,000 dollars a year
is a very good salary no question about
it but I think it might be more
appropriate to take a look at these
folks on Wall Street and corporate
America who in many cases of making four
or five hundred times what their work is
on making and take a very hard look at
the growing inequality in this country
we have 10 more minutes for your calls
for senator bernie sanders next is from
greensboro north carolina iran caller
good morning senator Sanders I I had a
statement to make and I'd also left
after a question historically there are
times for partisanship during uh for
instance the 1980 election which is when
I first registered to vote i registered
as a Republican because I thought that
the country was in such a situation that
we really needed a major change and I
think that in many ways elected Reagan
over reelected Carter was a good thing
there are also times in history when I
think that bipartisanship is not only
necessary but it's downright patriotic
now you as an independent obviously have
to some extent rejected the two-party
system what I hope my question to you
was what do you think about the the
partisanship that's going on now during
a national tragedy where we're at war in
two different locations and we have this
financial collapse don't you think that
a lot of the partisan rhetoric on both
sides uh is is really kind of
hair-splitting and that it's really time
now to put partisanship away i mean the
hypocrisy of some of the partisanship
now seems to just really not it I don't
I elbow on registered as a Republican I
don't really agree with their lack of
support for our new president or their
lack of acknowledgement of the situation
I wondered as an independent senator
said Mr Sanders I wonder what you have
to say about that well III think you
make a good point there are obviously
philosophical differences between people
in both parties and they're real when
people should treat each other with
respect I would say to the column
President Obama perhaps more than any
president that i can remember has really
it seems to me and i think that the
American people really reached out in
unprecedented ways to try to bridge the
gaps philosophically between the parties
and on on
this was that issue of the fact that
President Obama just the other day went
spent two hours as I understand it too I
was speaking to the Republicans in the
House I don't recall this is new recall
that about I can't I can't recall it
it's really unprecedented and that I
have to say I think it's really was not
a good sign they after spending two
hours asking for support of the stimulus
package you get zero Republican votes so
I agree with the cola that we need to
work together as best as possible within
these very very difficult moments in
American history I I was not impressed
by the the Republican rejection of
Obama's efforts in the house Chicago
good morning to you you're on for
senator Sanders good morning I support
the stimulus package at least the jobs
or I'm very concerned about the tax cuts
because from what I've been able to tell
most people want to get that extra ten
dollars in their paycheck immediately go
off to that big box store that routinely
forces offenders to shut down operations
here and take them over to China and so
we're doing a with you with these texts
such as seems that we're helping China
and career with the electronics and
instead of Americans we need to start
figuring out every dollar being a vote
well here's these what you got I mean
President Obama ran on the brain is
campaign and he said I'm going to give a
tax cut it up to a thousand dollars to
the middle class II ran on that he's
going to keep that promise and a lot of
folks who are hurting right now can use
that thousand dollars no question about
it the issue that you are raising though
about the fact that when we go to stores
almost well more often than not the
products that we bind are not made in
the United States that our manufacturing
capability has collapsed in recent years
we've lost millions of good-paying jobs
and when you go shopping it's China and
China or China maybe occasionally it's
Mexico but this issue speaks in my view
to the disastrous trade policies that we
have that's permanent normal trade
relations with China NAFTA the fact that
American corporations have shut down
plans all over this country from
millions of workers out on the street
moved to China and they're bringing the
products back into this country and
that's not blue collar jobs that is
increasingly white-collar jobs as well
so I am NOT a great fan of unfettered
free trade I think you need a good trade
policy which reflects the interest of
American workers and I think if these
large corporations want us to purchase
their products it's high time that they
started manufacturing their products in
this country and create decent paying
jobs here I hope this isn't too much of
a diversion but we're talking about
trade policy there's a front page story
in The Washington Post this morning
about the waning days of the Bush
administration the US as they say
declared war on Roquefort cheese
imposing a three hundred percent duty on
Roquefort in effect closing off the US
market Americans are declared will no
longer get to enjoy because of the the
tariffs concerns that this might incite
a trade war as a result now Vermont
being a cheese State I fight you have
opinions about this not Rockford freeze
the that's we're pretty we're more into
the cheddar cheese I might add I again
the issue here is everybody knows we
live in a global economy and trade is a
good thing I think our current trade
policies have been shaped by large
multinationals whose desire is cheap
labor abroad and being able to sell
those products back in this country i
think by and large that has been a
disaster for American workers we need to
take a rethink those policies very
seriously our next telephone call is
from [ __ ] on Wisconsin good morning good
morning thank you for taking my call
thank you for the good work that you do
in and what you do is my actual first
time meeting hearing you anyway I do
agree with some of your comm of what you
are saying I never agreed with NAFTA in
the first place because I thought this
is going to turn us into a third world
country fair and i'm pretty much
sneaking I'm right about this I also
want to make a comment about the what
we're in the financial mess when I
really think we're more in a depression
and I don't hear anybody saying that I
am saying it I live it I am a 45 year
old white woman I am
self-employed and massage therapist the
first thing people do in a financial
crisis is put their health on hold they
don't go to the dentist they don't go to
the doctor because they don't have the
money for it I you brought up a point
you brought up about the D regulations
and putting back the regulations I think
that is where we really first need to
start because you took the protections
away and also to getting a control on
the credit card companies and upping our
interest rates on our current dislike
their shut and I mean I had a card for
9.99 percent and it jumped to twenty
nine percent let me jump in there I love
it yeah i get i was on the financial
institutions committee so we worked on
on this issue here you have the insanity
of the federal government the American
taxpayers bailing out these large
financial institutions and then these
large financial institutions are
charging people twenty-five or thirty
percent on their credit cards that is
basically absurd so that is an issue
that has got to be addressed in terms of
whether in a deep recession or
depression I think what most economists
will tell you is that real unemployment
is substantially higher than official
statistics because the official
statistics do not include people what we
call discouraged workers people who have
given up looking for work they do not
include people at work in part-time who
want to work full-time so the
unemployment situation is in my view a
lot worse than the official statistics
indicate Fort Lauderdale good morning
Wow caller are you there are you a lot I
know what's happening is watching the TV
and not therefore question for a lot of
their last try I'm done here in South
Florida and the small businesses the
small businesses are extremely stressed
you seeing doors closed across the board
I believe the stimulus package would
work if you know there was some
conversation about putting a freeze on
income tax withholding from employees if
you want to stimulate the broad you know
population of the country you put that
tax back in each person's pocket it
helps with stopping for
sure it helps them go into these small
stores and start spending again I wanted
to ask the senator and thank the senator
for his candor I think you're a breath
of fresh air I also like to ask a second
question dear colleagues feel the same
way you do what percent Senate Senators
I have a patriotic spirit spirit as
yourself and I'm going to speak up about
these and justices and we shouldn't be
helping the banks for you know really
not loaning the money right now it is
it's just thought Thank You c-span's
first-time caller appreciate this is
true democracy and this is transparency
contagious listen on the air I would
concur with his applauding c-span c-span
is is a breath of fresh air in terms of
television uh in terms of tax policy I
think the coulomb makes the point that
President Obama has made and that is if
we give tax breaks to the middle class I
don't think it's going to solve all of
the problems but if they are targeted to
people who really need the money the
hope is that they're going to take that
money go out and spend it and create
other jobs in the process in terms of
the feelings of other members of the
Senate well I guess watch c-span right
and you can see the debates that take
place there is a broad range of feelings
about all of the issues that we have
discussed well to that end here's what
the christian science monitor says about
next week with the biggest spending bill
in american history on the line the US
Senate is gearing up for a debate for
the ages with the Senate Republicans at
41 and the 100-member body precisely
than ever they need to block legislation
with a filibuster Democrats could muscle
the bill over the line by breaking off
just one or two Republican votes how do
you see this playing out and what's the
time frame well it's going to be on the
floor next week I think it'll make very
good TV viewing I think the American
people want us to move this country in a
new direction they want us to invest in
creating millions of good-paying jobs
and dealing with our infrastructure and
dealing with our kids and dealing with
energy making more credit available to
small businesses and this is what the
stimulus package does
are in the house a president obama got
zero votes 0 votes i hope very much that
some of our colleagues in the Senate
will work with the president work with
those of us who see this country facing
an unprecedented crisis and we just
can't sit back and do nothing we've got
us not investing in our working families
and create the jobs that we desperately
need so to answer your question I hope
very much we're going to get the one or
two votes that we need senator Bernie
Sanders independent of Vermont member of
the Budget Committee also of the energy
energy committee and environment Public
Works and Veterans Affairs we thank him
for being here and taking your calls
we're going to take a quick break final
guest of the morning congressman Ron
Paul of Texas